Speaker 1: failed. Arizona Republican
gubernatorial candidate Carrie Lake
is panicking and deleting tweets. This
When I imagine someone deleting tweets,
even if they're doing it on their phone, I imagine
them feverishly typing on a keyboard. But that may
not be the case. She is panicking and deleting
tweets, attacking a judge after sanctions have
been demanded. So let's back it up and kind of
explain all of it. Kerry Lake lost the Arizona
gubernatorial election. And what I mean by lost
is her opponent, Katie Hobbs, got more votes
because more people voted for Katie Hobbs,
which means Katie Hobbs will be the governor.
Very simple and yet so complicated. Okay. She
won Kerry like lost Kerry like Sue's claiming,
really, she won. Her lawsuit was thrown out and
now she's just getting herself into more and more
and more trouble. The Hill reports Lake Deletes
Tweet Targeting Maricopa Judge After Officials
Seek Sanctions Defeated. Arizona gubernatorial
candidate Carrie Lake deleted a tweet accusing
the judge who dismissed her election challenge
of integrity violations. The tweet, posted early
Monday, suggested the founding partner of a law
firm representing Katie Hobbs emailed Maricopa
County Superior Court Judge Peter Thompson what
to say as he authored the dismissal. That's an
extremely serious charge to make against the
judge that someone wrote to him and said,
Here's your marching orders. Here's what
decision you will make in court. Quote,
The dismissal of Carrie Lake's election lawsuit
shows voter disenfranchisement no longer matters.
This is her tweet. Legal experts believe
his decision was ghostwritten. They
suspect top left wing attorneys like
Marc Elias emailed him what to say.
Maricopa County and Hobbs, in their capacities
as secretary of state and governor elect, cited
the tweet in asking the judge to impose sanctions
on Lake as well as on her attorneys, arguing that
Lake's Lakes Campaign's broader election challenge
was groundless and constituted harassment. So what
is it that is going on here? She is an annoyance,
yes, but she is an annoyance to a degree
that may actually deserve legal sanctions. And
so she's panicking. And so now she's deleting
the tweet. Now, as much as I would love to see
serious sanctions against Kerry, like, you know,
the right loves to talk about frivolous lawsuits.
Oh, the coffee was too hot. Turns out that was
actually a lawsuit that had some merit if you
actually learn about it. Oh, someone said Merry
Christmas to me and I'm offended. I don't know of
any lawsuit like that, but this is the caricature
of the right and the so-called frivolous
lawsuits they believe the left is engaged in,
even though we have many systems in place to
dismiss frivolous lawsuits. But it is actually
they who have no hesitation. They have no qualms
whatsoever gumming up the legal system after 2020,
with more than 60 different complaints in all
sorts of different jurisdictions for nothing,
for nothing. Trump lost. That's all that happened.
And similarly, Carrie Lake raising money,
filing lawsuits, hiring lawyers, bringing in
experts, taking up court time for something that
is obviously meritless and is, of course, going
absolutely nowhere. And now they're panicking
that they might be sanctioned if there is any good
news for Carrie Lake. And this sort of bugs me,
but it is what's going on. It's not really clear
that she is going to face those sanctions. Fox
News reports Arizona judge denies a request for
sanctions against Lake and rewards a $33,000
reimbursement. An Arizona judge denied a request
from Governor elect Katie Hobbs seeking sanctions
against Carrie Lake. Though the sanctions were
denied. The judge did award Hobbs a little
more than $33,000 to cover costs associated with
retaining expert witnesses during a two day trial
brought on by Lake challenging those results, Lake
lost her bid by half a percentage point, etc.,
etc.. Okay, so at. Least in this first finding a
judge is not issuing sanctions against Kari Lake.
What you have to understand here is
that there is a mishmash of political
stuff, for lack of that's a technical term going
on in Arizona, which includes right thinking and
clear minded people who see the entire Kerry
League fiasco for what it is terrible candidate
lost, panicked, is embarrassed and is trying
to sue anyone she can. But you also see some
judges in Arizona that are running a little bit
of interference for Kerry like saying, listen,
we believe she sincerely believed that she won.
And if Carrie Lake sincerely believed she won,
then most of her actions are acceptable in the
eyes of the law. It's sort of like covering for a
toddler's temper tantrum, arguing this particular
one was justified and does everything they did
and all of the sequels that resulted from that
tantrum are okay and we shouldn't be too harsh
as a result. How can someone like Kerry Lake be
considered a good candidate to lead anything in
government, whether it's being the administrator
of a state like Arizona or whatever, when she
can't even control her own impulses on Twitter
such that they start getting her into potential
legal trouble, and then she has to run and delete
the tweets. But it doesn't really matter. That's
really been Republicans for the last six years.
Who are the worst people we could possibly find
to do the jobs that are needed? Let's make
them our nominees. Many of my lawyer friends,
especially those that do criminal defense, say
that it is really, really common that their
clients just can't stop talking or they won't
stop talking either to the media or recently
in the modern era, more often social media posts.
And to some degree, that seems to be what's going
on here with Kerry Lake. Let's hope she does face
sanctions. Let's hope her attorneys do as well.